اهداف مشتركه جمعت رابطه العالم الاسلامي
بمنظمات امميه اثمرت عن عقد شراكات لتنفيذ
برامج في دول يعاني سكانها من مشاكل منها
الفقر والنزوح والحروب ابرز هذه الشراكات
تنفيذ الرابطه برامج تنمويه مشتركه مع
منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله اليونيسف في
دول مختلفه خلال السنوات الاخيره لتخفيف
معاناه الاطفال سواء كانوا لاجئين او
نازحين او من متضرري الحروب والكوارث
البرامج المشتركه بين الرابطه واليونيسف
هدفت في مجملها الى تعزيز وصول الاطفال
الى المدارس وضمان استمراريتهم في الدراسه
ومعالجه سوء التغذيه في بعض المناطق اضافه
الى تمكينهم من الحصول على الخدمات
الاجتماعيه الاساسيه الجيده عبر تقديم
الدعم النفسي والاجتماعي فضلا عن تنفيذ
برامج تطعيم ضد امراض منها شلل الاطفال
وفيروس كورونا وغيره من البرامج فبنهايه
العام 2022 وعبر هذه الشراكه تمكنت
الرابطه واليونيسف من تنفيذ مشاريع عده في
دول من هتشاد حيث اسفر برنامج واحد عن دعم
التحاق اكثر من ثلاثه الاف وستمائه طفل
بالمدارس وتدريب 60 معلما فضلا عن تاهيل
نحو 115 قياديا لدعم وتشجيع العمليه
التعليميه فضلا عن مراقبه سيرها اما في
اقليم دارفور في السودان تم العمل على
برنامج حمايه حقوق الاطفال على مستويات
عده منها معالجه سوء التغذيه الحاد وعمل
حملات للتطعيم ضد شلل الاطفال استفاد منها
نحو 9000 طفل وتمكين اكثر من 3000 طالب
للالتحاق بالمدارس وايضا تاسيس اربع شبكات
المجتمعيه لحمايه الطفل وتوعيته وحمايته
من العنف ودعمه نفسيا واجتماعيا للرابطه
ايضا شراكات اخرى منها شراكه مع مفوضيه
الامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين بهدف توفير
الدعم الانساني للاجئين ومحاوله دمجهم في
مجتمعاتهم الجديده حيث عقدت اتفاقيه لدعم
الاف اللاجئين وطالبي اللجوء في اليونان
لضمان حصولهم على الخدمات الاساسيه
وتاهيلهم للاندماج والمضي قدما في بناء
حياه جديده